wHaT uP gAmErS? It's Five Nights of Freddy's time
Everyone's favourite video game (u sure about that)
(Recalls all the backlash)
(phrog mating call)
i don't like this series, i think it's obnoxious, it has a lot of jumpscares (no shit)
and yes it startles you in the beggining...
but after a while it gets a bit repetitive
but it's out for vr as you can tell by my headset
and it actually looks pretty legit!
so i'm really really curious to see what this is all about
with (stroke) without further gaming ado, letsa frickina do da gAmInG
alright, letsa do da gaming
lets make a gaming everyone
boop
you think i need warnings?
im a gamer im used to w- games!
This is my hand!
oh my hand on my peepee (jesus christ)
my hand on my peepee! (rub rub)
[ happiness noise ]
Ok lets go! (oof)
yay! lets go! [Welcome to the Freddy fazbear virtual experience]
WEE [fazbear entertainment is excited to join the digital age, and whatever better way to do that than with an edge-of-a-seat virtual reality experience!]
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
[we know that fazbear entertainment has developed a bat reputation over the last few decades] oh you have, you have! [no shit]
[And while it's true that some stories are associated with our name] Oh god
[We're loosely based on actual events]
Oh, I see, chinese knockoff! (wot) [The majority of them were total fabrications from the mind of a complete lunatic...]
Of course! [(inaudibe)]
[But we all are laughing at ourselves] (felix laughing like a biatch)
[ha ha ha]
[thats why we have recreated many of these complete fictitious scenarios]
Oh, so you made them. (wot) [lies that have been fed over the last several years]
Incredible! [into a hilarious VR game]
Oh this is gonna be funny! [with hopes that we can finally move past these childish ghost stories]
[so we can develop a new relationship with you, as well as your kids (wot), dont forget the merch, perfect for birthdays (check out pewds merch tho)]
[so sit back and enjoy a few scares!]
so is this gonna be like five nights at freddy's in vr or- [we do have our (inaudible) that]
[so that you agree with a simple waver before-] (button bop)
You acknowledge that Fazbear's Entertainment is not responsible for accidental digital conciousness transference]
[Real world manifestations of digital characters; nightmares, night terrors night sweats-] (begone thot)
¿wot?
what did i just sign up for?
night terror and night sweats?
Ok I already have that [Welcome to the freddy fazbear virtual experience]
Sit next to marzia we use the (inaudible) ok... [we use the console infront]
[of you, to navigate the menu]
[and pick one of the frightening experiences available!]
[by completing these scenarios, more will become available!]
[you'll see plenty of familiar faces and some new ones as well] oh my god, i'm in the room! (no shit kjelberg)
[so stay a while, and have a good time!] (weird music)
[despite the temporary horror you may experience]
[this is a completely controlled environment!] ¿wot?
[and you aren't in any real dan-] (begone thot again)
AAA MY HAND
So, it's five nights at freddy's VR
did i just spend five minutes to play five nights at freddy's vr? (no)
ok, this is pretty- ¿OH GOD THIS IS SCARY!
Uh god, herro?
Hewwo, howwo?
¿HoWwO?
Hewwo? Howwo!
[Hello?] Hewwo! (don't worry the autism hasn't even started)
SHUT UP (rude)
NO [I wanted to record a message for you]
[to help you get settled out on your first night]
AEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOU
[I actually worked at that office]
AEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOUAEIOU
what a difference (wot)
[there's nothing to worry about, you'll be fine!]
The stakes are real now! [so let's just focus]
Easy, Mr. Cupcake!
You'll be my friend [A magical place where kids and grown-ups alike]
God Dammit! (think about the kids pewds)
Alright, you protect me! [a missing file report will be found]
am i missing any? [within ninety days]
[(inaudible) cursed now! (inaudible)]
CAN YOU SHUT YOUR FRICKING PIPEHOLE (SICK BURRRNN)
AAA, where did buddy go!? [just remember]
WHERE DID BUDDY GO??
[(inaudible cupcake mumble-jumble)]
[we need to show them a little respect] WHERE DID BUDDY GO?!
[alright, ok!]
(pasta language) where did buddy go?
[just be aware]
['s pizza]
[they'll probably try to forcefully stuff you inside a Freddy Fazbear suit] (button bopping)
¿Ay?
(phone droppo froggo)
oh god!
[yeah, they don't tell you these things when you sign up] what is that? they're closed!
[but hey, first day should be a breeze]
oh god, they're all out!
[i'll chat with you tomorrow. Check those cameras and remember to close the doors if absolutely necessary!] i think i should probably-
aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa (weakling scream)
[alright, good night]
(pasta pewds) Oh my god, he was right there!
Where's the chicken?
Chicken is still there, we're fine.
[you suck at this game felix] I know!
I've never been good at these, that's why I hate these, he's literally outside.
GO AWAY
GGOO AAWWAAYY
no-one likes bunnies anyways
god, it's so laggy dude (no it ain't) ! oh god...
Does that mean he's here?
oh god, he's coming!
okay, okay, okay
he's still there, GO AWAY PLEASE (no)
(sheep sounds) i hate this job!
Why did I ever take to this job?! (being a youtuber is shit)
Okay, we can open this now
BAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
Okay, we can open, oh wait!
GET OUTTA MY HOUSE
Okay, I think it want.
Yeah yeah, he left so now
okay, we're fine
this is great!
actually goin' pretty good
okay!
Okay!
I'm starting to know (booping tha camera)
It's actually useful to switch your cameras!
Especially without the cupcake guy!
(2013 memes)
So where did bunny go?
(chica jumpscares warning)
where is that coming from?
I have no power! (chica jumpscare) AAA (rip he was so close)
I hate this stupid game!
Why do they scare me? I wasn't even scared!
Cupcake, I trusted you!
God Damn it!
It's fine, it happens to the best of us. I wasn't even scared!
It's called, swedish kong fu and it's
It's all about wailing your hands around your face, to make sure it's safe
Okay? (no what did we just witness)
It's completely normal, it's completely safe and-
It's been approved by people everywhere (o rlly)
Please, for the love of god, don't make the guy call me again
That's all I want...
YOU SUCK
[sorry felix] 2013 pewdiepie
[phone call] oh he calls already, dude!
do something!
Do something (finally, my swedish kong fu comes to power!)
(check if the nightmare's real)
Where is everyone? There's bunny, okay
And who the hell is that ugly kid?
(kjelberg tears)
So what time is it? It's 1AM...
I gotta make this six right?
Okay
The light thing is like
really efective
Because you forget your surrounded
(random jingle) what does that mean?
AAAA
GO AWAY BUNNY BOY!
GOOO AWAYYYY
GO AWAY
STOP
AAA
Where is she?
What does that mean?
AAA AA
FUCK OFF, FUCK OFF, FUCK OFF, GO, NO!
NO
AAA DOORS
Okay
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
I'M DRAINING ALL MY ENERGY!!!!!
GO AWAY
Okay, this is fine
Okay, alright, we're fine
and
SHE'S GONE, WE CAN GO! It's easy!
[foxy + jingle]
oh god, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, I DON'T KNOW ENGLISH HELP MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
Alrgiht
Okay, okay, alright, okay, i get it, it's a party
alright
i think we're doing okay!
i think we are doing okie-dokie-sucky-mocky
Alright, I do here someone walking, i don't know if
i should look
it's fine, i have plenty power left
just keeping it real at this point (kjelberg tears)
I DEFINITELY HEARD SOMEONE
AAA DOOR
YES, YES, SUCK ON MY SWEDISH MEATBALLS
(weak dab)
[yay] yeah
yeah
okay, i did it
i did something in my life, i completed the easiest level
and i feel incredibly proud of myself (what an achievement)
game one, claim your prize, oh it better be a good prize...
(mimicking jingle)
[YAY] oh!
[hey, i'm your friend, let's fuck]
no, no, no, no (i don't know what the fuck is happening in the background)
Okay, FNAF 2 time, showtime!
Let's go, letsa go, let's go
no thanks, don't want anything
they become more active Mr. Cupcake!
[Oh that really SUCKS (fucking dies)]
don't care, you cupcake virgin
(2012 memes)
Oh look, there's like a dining- (kjelberg tears)
okay, i'm not in danger, it's good
pirate cove, this one!
Oh yeah, Foxy comes out.
Oh no, Mr. Pirate is waking
AAA
fuck
son of a snake!
these snakes are everywhere!
so it's safe now, right? (no)
yeah
no?
(pasta language) fuck you!
sucka my meatball!
go away, no-one like a chicken!
I vegetariano
I very good (inaudible)
(stroke sounds)
FUCK OFF
get away from ma house
my beautiful- ay!
Mister! I don't like you.
alright have you gone? he's gone, and he's gone!
GO AWAY
It's fine, it's fine, everything's fine
e v e r y t h i n g  i s  f i n e
I'm keeping my eyes on you!
AAAA SHUT THE FUCK UP, JUST CLICK THE FUCKING DOOR
THAT IS TOTAL BULLCRAP, I WAS TOTALLY (breaks neck)
ah, it squeezed my neck! My neck muscles were ready to explosion!
Alright, this time. I keep my eye-
Shut your fricking pie
I was so close to clicking on it...
so bullcrap...
[you weren't fast enough felix!]
yeah, well i tried god damnit!
from time to time i did, i flipping did bro...
god damn pirates, you never know what they're gonna do
they always come for your booty.
has it come out yet?
who's playing music at this hour????
there you are you sexy son of a- I would frick chica (ffs crying emoji)
No shame, i'm not even a furry, Chica thicc as fricc
I don't even find birds that attractive
But Chic, chica's beak- there you are you son of a snake!!!!
chica does bring something out of me that i can-t
OH CHICA MOVED, CHICA'S ON THE MOVE (OH SHITTTT)
CHICA'S ON THE MOVE, CHICA CHICA
cha cha cha
alright, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay alright, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay alright, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay alright, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay
I am made for chica, ay
not yet, not yet, not yet
THE DOOR IS CLOSED SORRY, SORRY DOORY
SORRY DOORY, DOOR IS CLOSED
AAA, FUCK YOU MAN
frick you doing here man?
STOP
listen
Yo eyes is about to be mis-
OH, YOU HIT THE DOOR
YOU HIT THE DOOR YOU DUMMY
YOU DUMMY
CHICA COMING
HEY CHICA HOW YOU DOING, YOU WANNA COME TO MY HOUSE?
WELL TOO BAD, THATSA TOO BAD CHICA
this is my house and no-one can enter
okay, sorry
sorry, i forgot
alright, you're cool,  right?
Alright, we're doing pretty good
Chica there.
Chica here
Chica in my chair
Chica in my hair
Chica ate my pear
Chica has a pair
Oh, cheeky boobs
I like them
I love them
I like them, i love- HEY CHICA, YOU WANNA COME TO MY HOUSE?!
TOO BAD
i am sorry, you cannot come into my house
why? because i do not like you!
check the pirate cove, it's safe!
EVERYTHING IS AWESOME (no)
EVERYTHING IS COOL WHEN YOU'RE PART OF THE DREAM
HEY, YOU WANNA COME TO MY HOUSE?
SORRY, MI CASA EL NO MI CASA
THANK YOU
i'm killing it dude!
oh god
AY CHICA, WANNA COME TO MY HOUSE?
HELL YEAH
I DID IT AGAIN
i'm so good at games
(japanese shit)
open gift time!
[YAY] oh!
glug! glug! glug! glug! glug!!!
I didn't mean to eat it, I wanted to drink it obviously...
dumb game
night 3, let's go, let's go bros
honestly, i wanna play the game, like i'm really good at video games!
people don't understand that i'm a  P R O  G A M E R
this is what i do, so now Freddy comes out I think
how much am I paid by the way?
Is it like a Jake Paul (inaudible)?
for the fun and fam? Oh god i can't see anything!
i lost tracking!
oh, look at you, big boy! Okay i gotta be ready on the door here
NO (HITLER SPEECH)
i'm done
Alright, that was five nights at freddy's VR, hope you guys enjoyed, smash like, subscribe if you want more.
and i'll see you guys next time, bye bye! (no come back)
(pop)
(sponsor)